talking about these foreign enemies of
ours either from
another universe or from right across
the ocean
compare the army ads this is this has
now gone viral
two army ads that are that are running
one out of russia
one the aforementioned lesbian woke
army ad in the united states which
do you think represents a better
prepared
army going in the right direction
a james bond villain jumping out of
airplanes
got guns full of rounds
shooting at their enemies with a little
girl
raised by two moms oh my gosh i also
marched for equality oh my goodness
i like to think i've been defending
freedom from an early age
oh my goodness marry my other mom
with such powerful role models i
finished high school at the top of my
class
and after meeting with an army recruiter
i found it
a way to prove my inner strength i'm us
army corporal emma malone lord and i
answered my call
so if you're walking down a back
alleyway somewhere at night
and you see the
the russian guy with the guns with the
black rifles
which is going to be more intimidating
that guy or the little girl sort of
blushing on santa monica pierre talking
about how wonderful
her lesbian mothers are and how she's
been fighting for freedom her whole life
free presumably by freedom here she's
referring to the redefinition of
marriage which even
even barack obama opposed like eight or
nine years ago hillary clinton when they
ran for
president they said marriage is a sacred
union between a man and a woman
so this infantry woman
is obviously way more woke than even the
most
left-wing presidents we've had i suppose
until joe biden
now why why is this why are they pushing
this out there i actually
i think i understand the logic between
the behind the u.s army and the cia
pushing this out
they believe we're not going to fight
real wars anymore it's all going to be
propaganda wars it's all going to be
messaging
it's all going to be drip drab drip drab
from the government and foisting that on
the rest of the world
and our most lethal propaganda that we
can put out there is this woke
insanity so they are trying to recruit
people for that
it's the it's the last institution that
hasn't been totally taken over by the
left the military but they're trying to
i think a lot of the officer class has
been
and now they're saying yeah we don't
want guys who look like that crazy
russian
we want super woke girls who are far to
the left of barack obama
who all they want to talk about is their
lesbian mothers
we want them because that that will be
the final institution to fall and and by
the way there is a strategic purpose
here
they're very good at propaganda very
very good at
politics on the woke left in this
debate here over the woke army ad in the
woke
cia ad for instance we compare it to the
russian army ad where it's the crazy guy
with the giant muscles shooting guns and
and we we laugh about that
but in our public discourse you're not
really allowed to suggest there's
anything wrong
with the the woke army ad are you what's
wrong
are you saying it's wrong to redefine
marriage
are you are you a bigot are you a phobe
you must be a
are you saying it's wrong for two
lesbian women to raise a child who knows
whose child it is but
are you saying that's wrong that's
somehow not the same as a husband and a
wife raising a child how dare you
you saying it's wrong that this
girl is fighting in combat are you how
dare you you're
you're really not allowed i mean i guess
we'll do it on this show for as long as
they let us stay in the air
to suggest huh maybe you know maybe that
isn't ideal maybe they're you know there
are
more ideals ways of of raising children
or
fighting wars but we'll say it but
you're not really allowed to say that at
universities
at the workplace you're not really
allowed to in the government certainly
you're not you're not allowed to say it
anywhere
so much for academic freedom there's
always going to be boundaries on these
things
ah you know what i'm gonna say i don't
even need to say it it should be out you
should have done it already
ring that bell subscribe like
the video make sure that you get the
notifications i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you